hi everyone it's great to have the
opportunity to speak with you all today
uh my name is hanson i head up our lab
automation
automata uh which is automation
company and you'll hear a bit more from
my colleague later who
heads up the commercial side of our lab
automation
team automata
like myself didn't come focused on
life sciences when we first started out
we
we started from a place of trying to
solve a problem not in laughs but a
problem in automation as a whole
what we found was that when we put our
first
product to market which was eva robot
which you can see on my
left and my right which is the most
affordable industrial rover arm
on the market when we when we launched
that two and a half years ago
what we saw was a huge demand from
levels which
and i think a massive reason for that
demand
is everything that we've seen over
covered period i think what we've all
witnessed
is this incredible tragedy
that's happened across the globe but
from a
personal point of view of someone in
automation what i felt
is the sense of failure this massive
sense of failure
in the inability of automation
to react in the way that everyone would
want
and hope in a crisis like that
what we've seen is that in this crisis
people have you know in the
for the far most flexibility and the
quickest
results i've turned to people to do
incredibly repetitive
tasks rather than to automation
and when i say people what i'm talking
about so often
is eminent scientists eminent doctors
eminent professors being pulled out of
their all-important day jobs
in order to do incredibly repetitive
tasks
and so many of them have volunteered to
do this and they have been celebrated
across the world and that is absolutely
right they shouldn't
but like i say all that gives me is also
a sense of saving
because why was automation there to mean
that they could carry on
with those important jobs that involved
their enrollment huge amount of
experience
and expertise rather than being pulled
into jobs that didn't
in the uk they said we set up a load
of uh covenant testing facilities to
respond to that and this happened across
the world
but one of those facilities started
doing this vlog which was a meet the
team blog
and the reason i want to share one of
the slight
this slide in this extract from it is
because it was the best summary
of that emotion that i felt and why i
was feeling
what we have is some in this scientist
dr stone elworthy
who had 28 years experience
in immunity and cardiovascular disease
it's pretty important in a time like
yoga to realize
those are some pretty important things
to continue folks
and yet dog spinel where they gave up
focusing on that research in order to
volunteer at this testing lab
so once those 28 years boiled down what
was the theme that
he could do that no one else could
well that thing was to take a sample to
start
volatility and to protect from that
sample
into a place and what was the expertise
he was breaking
the ability to to identify a 96-hole
plate
and the ability to use it to pet doesn't
seem like the right criteria
to pull someone like dr stone elworthy
off what he was doing before to help
and it doesn't sound like a sort of
thing that people
do that thousands of times a day times a
day
are ever going to be the right people
to solve that problem
but it didn't surprise me that everyone
went this way
because somehow we've ended up in this
space
where we have robots that can do parkour
we've got robots that the year before
producing 81 million
cards and we've got robots in response
to kobe's
can now give a tattoo remote
and yet we don't have robots or
automation is not seen as a fast enough
tool
to solve the the kind of job that does
so now worthy
is brought into
and that speaks a lot to the heritage of
automation it speaks a lot
to where automation came from which is
this place
where it costs hundreds of millions of
dollars to set up it's a
bespoke facility for you for you it
takes
years to develop backness developed by
experts for experts
and maintained by experts
and automation came from a place of
doing things that people can't
not what people should
so automation is inherently failing in
this aim of allowing humans to be more
human
[Music]
instead so instead we pull on people
like dr stone elworthy
to come in and solve that and that's why
we end up in this place where in the lab
you're so much more
likely to hear the phrase rsi
than you are
this isn't just a problem that
has happened because of coronavirus all
that happened
is that coronavirus has shot a light
on the cracks that were already in place
because dr stonell
is going to go back to his research lab
and he's going to have the same problems
he's going to find that 70
of the time his peers can't replicate
its results
and it's worth 50 of the time he can't
represent its own
results and it comes back to that line
and allows humans to be more human
humans are inherently bad at doing stuff
incredibly repetitive and that is a
great thing
but we have to make sure that automation
can do those things
for us
so we find ourselves in this weird space
this space where
media and public perception is one where
automation can do everything automation
is taking over for better or for worse
depending on
your point of view but the truth and the
reality
is that we have these brilliant
scientists
sat doing incredibly repetitive
incredibly mundane results
to achieve amazing goals for humanity
so to waste it's a waste about
intelligence
of those people it is a waste of
businesses resources
and it is a waste of the technology that
is available now and is becoming
rapidly more and more available over the
next few years
the automation still needs to go further
and the way that we give an automaton
there are three main problems that we
have so
one is the affordability you shouldn't
need
hundreds of millions of dollars to set
up to start engaging with automation
and getting benefit from the second is
accessibility
you shouldn't need to depend on an
expert who is going to come in and tell
you it has to be this way that is the
way it is
it's completely fit and go this way or
it won't work
you should be able to leverage that
yourself
and it should be flexible enough that
when your business priorities inevitably
change
in six months time or some crisis
happens like the one we've just seen
people feel confident and safe reaching
for automation
rather than reaching for what they've
tried and tested
which is overqualified over-intelligent
people
being used for repetitive monday tasks
at automata we've had the pleasure of
being involved in setting up a fully
automated test
trader testing facility as part of the
uk national effort
to increase that testing capacity and
it's been an amazing
amazing experience been amazing to watch
how motivated
empowered driven the team automatically
have been about solving this problem and
it's completely understandable right
right we've all felt
the pace of this but it has also been
incredible
to watch the way that
that automatic team has been able to
react to the problems and the changes
that have happened in that project what
we've watched
so much is industrial is
incumbent in this industrial space
develop something overly
bespoke offer something overly bespoke
only for
the science around the tests we're
processing to change
because those are being developed at the
same time
and that whole system has to be rewrote
or no longer work
and instead by being able to use modern
technology instead by being able to use
modern techniques
and approaches to technology
we've been able to solve that and react
to those changing needs because it isn't
right that an automation company should
say you have to get everything
completely fixed everything answers to
me is what i can do
i'd love to tell you more about this
project i'm sure i will see you
know if you can't but
as i said it will be it'll be great when
when we can
what i do want to focus on though is to
talk about
if you're looking on how
you can get benefit out of automation
where you should be looking and so often
we talk about the automation in this
high throughput line
technology the one that's most similar
of course
to car production very similar to drug
production
but that isn't the only place and that
certainly often isn't the most
beneficial place most organizations
of the spectrum far more simple but
often
the most beneficial is this idea of
automated decision
that that workstation that task
that people are doing day in and day out
and you've got that person just stood
there
doing some repetitive mundane talks
that's a great place to start as you
approach it in the right way then what's
great is that
you might start for example by
automating a liquid handler
but very quickly you can add into that
incubator reader and suddenly you can
automate an entire
approach in an entire asset entire
experiment
and that's what we want to talk to you
about is if you're going and looking
how how into automation how should you
actually appraise that how should you
start and
the fact is you should start them always
try
and focus it down to the simplest thing
that will give you the most benefit
quickly
but make sure you build around flexible
products make sure you build
around the kind of technology that is
going to be able to enable you to then
do the next step and the next step again
more and more
because if you take all industrial
approaches to automation you're going to
build something so bespoke
what you've just conceptualized now
in six months time you're gonna have to
do that all over again
in order to change that system to me
and that goes hand in hand with picking
your problem
automation isn't a place where unless
you really have
that expertise within your company
you're probably going to need support
but make sure you've hit the right
partners for you
so often in automation
the number of years that that company
has been around autism stuff
is actually quite a bad reflection of
whether they're the right partner to do
so often this is an old-fashioned old
start old technology approach to a
problem
that makes it expensive slow and
inflexible
so make sure that you go with a company
that is adopting new technology make
sure you go with a company that makes
this simple for you
that feels like you are part of that
process
and they're not just putting your horse
and make sure you go to someone
where they're invested in getting you to
success not just
charging you a day there's loads more to
say about this
and i hope that this speech will start
to get you interested in what you can do
and if it is then please go and read our
beginner's guide to lab information it's
there for people like you
it's there to give you an overview of
the things that you should start
thinking about the way you should
start to assess opportunities
it's on our website we might be able to
send the link out afterwards so
i'll try and get that sent to you but
please read it
and more importantly please talk to us
we're always happy to listen to what
you're trying to do
we're always happy to tell you if
there's something we can help with
or if it's not if there's a partner that
can help you
and in the occasional situation
tell me that maybe your idea is a bit
crazy
let's start with something else
what i want to do now is hand over to
craig
how i introduced the start who created
your demo of a system we developed
and the purpose of this demo is to give
you um
first that demo is to give you a sense
of the technology
that's coming with technology what to
expect from
automation on those three things we
talked about performance about
accessibility
there's only your customers only if
people in industries are expecting more
of
the automation industry but we'll truly
start to see the change that we all want
to see
and that increment
[Music]
so i get to do the fun bit of the
webinar today and let's take what nick
has been talking about in the abstract
sense or through some stories or
research
and show you what the next wave of lab
automation is going to look like
in a practical sense before i do
we are recording this in advance and
mainly because i'm running on a three
camera setup
so i've got one here and one over there
and one on the far sides and i'm
recording my screen as we have to show
you some software
and i've done enough zooms over the past
year to know live streaming that would
be absolute chaos
and so we're recording this morning of
about jump back in afterwards with nick
to answer some questions um so
i'm craig uh i am the writer producer
director for this bit
uh but more commonly i am the commercial
lead automator for lab automation
and what that means is i get to spend my
days talking to
people in labs in a range of industries
so in pathology in university research
groups
and tiny little biotech startups are
massive corporate formal organizations
and i get to do a really exciting thing
which is change their perspective on
what lab automation can be
i'm moving them from this place of
thinking of lab automation
as this um massively costly
inaccessible unflexible thing uh to
something exciting vibrant and new
and it's a really great job i really
enjoy it um
so if nick's done his job right we
should be about halfway through the
session today so that leaves me about 15
minutes
to run you through a practical demo um
of some lab automation setup we've got a
range of equipment here
from a range of different providers i'll
run you through it in just a minute um
but 50 minutes is not long
um but what we're going to do is show
you how much you can achieve
in just that 15 minutes maybe even less
it depends
on how long i'm offloading on for um and
really give you an idea of
what is possible in lab automation and
that's what we wanted to leave you with
today
it's not a sense that um our automata
robot is
amazing and incredible you should buy
woods and i mean i would love for that
to happen
uh but what i want to do today is leave
you with a little bit of inspiration
and that's inspiration to go back to
your lab and
and look at your processes with a new
set of eyes
and and that's starting to think about
what could be possible with this next
wave of lab automation
so looking at your lab processes the
assays that you're running
what steps are the most boring what
steps can we cut out
where can we utilize your highly capable
highly trained people
bet in better places than doing highly
monotonous tasks
and that's the one thing i want to leave
you with at the end of this 15 minutes
so without further ado i am going to
kick off our demo
and show you the next wave of affordable
accessible
and flexible lab automation and the
easiest one to start with is affordable
so let's go over here to my lab
automation setup
so this is the setup that we're going to
demo today and we've got a few different
bits of equipment here
uh from a few different providers so uh
here we have the
ot2 liquid handler from opentrons uh
opendraws very much being one of the
pioneers of this
move for affordable accessible lab
automation
we have a stand here prevention and just
to put these two on
we've got standard lab h a micro blade
here which you're very familiar with
and for that micro plate we have a
microplate gripper and the gripper
itself being from a german company
called zimmer
and then we just made some custom metal
fingers uh that worked for a standard
microplate sample
and then what we have here is the glue
that is going to hold this automation
system together
and that is the eva robot from automata
and that's what we're going to focus on
today
before i do i said the first thing i was
going to talk about was affordability
so when we look at the system as a whole
uh we are talking
less than 20 000 which is quite
incredible for the world of lab
automation traditionally you know you're
thinking of a starting price at six
figures
and you're going up from there so that's
what's happened all of this
and the potential for a fully automated
system at around twenty thousand dollars
and it's really massive cost savings
there and when you think about the
comparable throughput
the higher degree effects flexibility
and that minimum extra atk
which i'm sure you could allocate to
many many exciting things that you want
to do in your lab
and so when you talk affordability this
system has it
we'll focus then as i said on the eva
robot
and the glue in this automation system
and so eva is a six axis industrial
robot
and so it has six jugs we have joint one
down here
which is a big rotational drip
we have two and three here which is your
lean forwards
and back jokes we have chart four here
which is just like your forearm it's a
rotational joint
so they can go in and around like that
we have axis five here which is very
much the rest of the robot
so it's not engineering just there and
then move back to six
which is your final rotational axis here
and those six axes give you six degrees
of freedom
uh which gives you ultimate flexibility
in automating your athlete and so that
makes it easy
to move things from different levels so
from the lower lab [ __ ]
up to the bed of the open fronts here it
helps you manipulate in and around
microplate readers and if they have
cartridges coming out
and it just gives you that ease of
movement to get around everything that
you're going to want to motivate around
and to control the eva robot we have a
piece of software called choreograph
so we have two buttons on the front of
the robot here and this is the first one
that we're going to use
and it's the back driving button now the
back driving button when i press it
it releases the brakes on all the joints
here
and that gives me ultimate control of
the robot and that means i can drag it
and drop it
into any position that i immediately the
robot itself has a reach bar of 600
millimeters
so i can come 600 ml from the base you
can see it coming right around there
and that's around the length of the
human arm and so anything
a human can reach the robot can reach
and what you see in choreograph is when
i move it around there
the live robot and choreograph following
those positions around
so you always have an idea of where your
robot is in space and choreographed
now we've got the second button here
which is the set of waypoint
and that saves those positions that we
move the robot into
and that means we can start to build a
tool path from the points that we save
along the way
so what we're going to do today is
automate a really really simple process
which is loading this microplane
into one of the bays and the open trunks
and we've got a little reservoir
with some reagent that we're just going
to put that into a couple of the
couple of slots on the microplate and uh
from there
we'll unload the microplane right back
to where we started
i'll just show you that really really
simple process you can start to think
how would this apply to me and how this
applies to my lab
so let's get started by um picking up
the microplane with the robot
so you can see here in choreograph i
have no points saved
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
back drag the robot into position
to pick up that first microphone
so we have black driving
we're going to come right down to you
and then we're going to save that point
using the same wavelength button
so what you can see now is the virtual
robot has moved into the position
of the physical robot and if i click
here you can see we have point one
saved there hovering over the microplate
and there's a couple of things we need
to do to point one before we can pick up
that microplate
and the first is to level the head of
the robot um
and we do that really simply by right
clicking here
and you saw the robot adjust there and
what that does is allow us to pick up
a range of different mic uh lab wears
from a flat surface so
petri dishes uh or micro plates
makes it really easy to get an even hold
on them
and now instead of back driving the
robot again
and all i need to do is make a movement
straight down to pick up that microplate
and so i'm not going to do that
physically i'm going to do that within
the software
and i'm going to use two functions to
achieve that the first
is the clone button here so we turn 0.1
into 0.2
and then we're going to use the absolute
movement function
now if i take a look the robot looks to
be about
40 mil above where it needs to be
so i am going to bring this down from
205.8
to 165. we're going to move that down
and you'll see in the software it's
created 0.2 there 40 ml down from 0.1
and because that we're just moving
through one axis it's going to be a
straight movement
right down onto the sides of that
microplane
so all i'm going to do now is hit send
to to move the robot there in real life
and we'll see how we get on
and if we take a look at that now
i can see that's slightly too high for
me
so what we're going to do is just set
that down a few more mil
about five mil let's see
[Music]
so now that we've set our waypoints
we're going to do our first bit of
robotic programming
and to do that i'm just going to pull up
the timeline at the bottom here
and what we need to do is drag and drop
our waypoints onto that timeline to
create a tool path
and the robot will work through that two
paths sequentially each step in order
uh so we're going to start at point one
the point above the microplate
we're then going to move down to point
two which is the point which we pick up
the microplate and then we're gonna go
back
to point one
and when we're at point two
and when we're at point two we need to
close the jaws of the gripper
so to do that i'm going to set some
outputs on the end effector io
of the robot which is a wired to the
gripper that we have so i'm going to
set end effector digital one
to zero and i'm going to set end
effector digital two
to one and all it's going to do is send
two digital signals
and instruct the gripper to close its
jaws
so whenever we pick something up it's
always good practice to put a weight in
and that's just going to be of
0.2 seconds there
and the last thing that we're going to
do is make sure that at the start of
every tool path
our gripper jaws are open so
so all i'm going to do is basically set
the reverse of what i've set here
at the start of the tool path so in
defective digital one to zero
or one to one even and end effector
digital two to zero
and that means every time we start the
gripper is in the right position for us
to pick up that microplate
all we need to do now is upload that
tool past the robot
hit home to go to the first position
and then hit play
so now that we've picked the microplate
up what we're going to do is program it
to move rounds
over and into the open drums so i'm just
going to do what i did earlier with the
back driving which is press down that
button here
and we're going to guide it with two
hands
so we're going to bring it right back up
in here
and i'm going to save that one and then
we're going to rotate right
here and we're going to save that point
as well
and that means that the robot isn't
going to swing around and go right in
we've got a safe trajectory into the
machine and as you can see there in
choreograph
uh the robot now and that's enough right
ready to move in
so when we're putting the microplate in
we're almost going to do the exact
opposite of what we did earlier so
earlier we hovered over the microplate
and then we moved down to pick it up
whereas this time all we're going to do
is we're going to move the microplate
right into position
so press right against the base
like that and then we're going to save
that waypoint
and then in chronograph all we're going
to do is duplicate that waypoint
and move it up by that 40 mil we moved
it up by earlier so it's around this
position
that means we can get that straight
vertical pick up and we won't catch any
of the lab word in there
okay so what i'm going to do now is jump
into choreograph do that a little
duplication
so that's my first bit of editing
trickery i've just duplicated that point
like i did
earlier um but we started i guess eight
minutes ago now
and we've got all the building blocks
that we need to program our full tool
path
so now we're gonna program it all the
way through we've got that first pickup
started
and from point one once we picked up the
microplate we want to go to point three
and then we wanna go around to point
four
we then want to go to the point above
the microplate deck which is the point
we cloned 0.6
we go down to 0.5
and back up to 0.6
and again at 0.5 we want to put down the
microplate so i'm going to do exactly
what i did at the start
and add two outputs to put it down
it's a one zero again
so hopefully you're starting to get a
picture of how straightforward this
would be for you to program yourself
and indeed how easy it would be to make
changes in the future
and so if you're looking to say
you know change the position in the open
trends that you'd load it into
all you need to do is change points six
and five and the rest of the tool path
stays exactly the same we saw how quick
it was to program in those waypoints
earlier
the last thing that we need to add is a
signal to the opentrons to start the
liquid handling protocol that we've
pre-loaded onto it
i've connected them via a digital wire
again so all we need to do is send
a signal this time on the base digital i
o
and we're going to send a one along that
and all that's going to do is trigger
the opentrons to start
and then we're going to head back up to
four
to make sure we're out the way when it
kicks off
and so now the only thing i need to do
is
program the micro plate unloading from
the open runs
and uh really simple we've got all the
points already
so we're just going to program what
we've programmed there in reverse
and there's one change that i need to
make and that's that we are
waiting for a signal from the open trans
this time so i'm going to load it in on
an f branch
and that branch is conditional on
getting a
digital signal from the opentrons
i can move this out of the way
so we'll go input this time
on base digit two that'll be a one again
when we get that signal back from the
opentrons uh we're going to kick off the
unloading process
uh it's going to be a bit boring to see
me do the reverse uh so i'll do my
second and final bit of interesting
trickery
and uh put the rest in before we kick
things off
okay so now we're going to demonstrate
that food tool path that we just
programmed
running as is so i'm going to hit go on
our software
you'll see the robot coming down there
to pick up the microplate and the
opentron's homing at the same time
so once we place that microplate into
the
bay that we put it in it's going to
trigger the opentrons to go
and start pipetting and we've just done
a really basic
two cycles of competing we don't want to
run through the phone 96 it's going to
be quite boring for you all
uh so that's just for petting down into
the first hole
and then you'll see the opentrons run
through that seconds per betting motion
just about now there we go
so once that's done all it's going to do
is communicate back to the robot
that's ready to come in it's ready to
pick up the microplate
and place it back down on the table
where we picked it up from before
so let's dispense the perpetuit pads
communicating back to the robot and here
we go in
and nice and simple
there we go right back to where we
started
so there we have it a really really
simple demo there but it should start to
give you an idea of what is going to be
possible in the next wave of lab
automation
you saw how easy the software was to use
you saw how easily the robot was
it's a move it's a program and if my
little sexual neph you can do it with a
chocolate ginger here it is aggressive
scottish accent and
no industrial automation experience at
all then you can do it too
and as we say that's a really really
dead simple demo it's a single
microplate
into a single deck or a liquid handler
but when you start to think they're
after
that's where things get really really
exciting so instead of a single
microplate
imagine we've got a microplate hotel
there and we can
load in 24 micro plates for 44 micro
plates
and you can set it up at 5 p.m it will
load them all through the night and you
come in at 8 00 am the next day
and your experiments are ready to run
and you've saved a whole
load of time maybe instead of a plate
hotel we have a microplate reader
and you can start to think about
automating a full asset and they
were speaking to a customer just
yesterday and they wanted to automate
the reading of microplates
and they could do that two ways they
could spend six figures
you know hundreds of thousands of pounds
on a expensive computational microplate
reader
or they could buy a robot an incubator
and a basic microplate reader and they
could string them all together for less
than 30k
that's a huge cost saving and it also
gives them much more flexibility to
change that experiment in the future to
react
to the discoveries that they make and
that's where things as i say get really
really exciting in this industry as i
said at the top
all i wanted to leave you with today was
a little bit of inspiration
and so i'd love for you in the next few
days to go back into your labs
to take a look at those new processes
and think about what you can do with
this new wave of affordable
accessible and flexible automation if
you want any support in doing that
please reach out to us
and we'll jump into the questions in
just a bit and i think it's about four
hours time for me it's probably about
five minutes time for you
and we'll leave my contact details at
the end and maybe even if you're not
looking for a sex access robot
we're well connected in this field and
we can maybe connect you to some of the
right providers we're really
part of the start of a growing movement
here there's other people like
opentrons or flow robotics or automata
who
are leading the charge on this next week
with lab automation and we can make sure
that you speak to the right people
in those companies um so thank you very
much for sticking with me today
and i hope you enjoyed the demo and as i
say we'll be back very soon to answer
any of your questions
so thanks for your time and then back
over live
cheers
hopefully that um demo gave you a bit of
a flavor of what we're talking about and
a bit of a
insight into what you should be looking
for and expecting
and creating now join me and we're gonna
do some questions in a bit
but before we get into that there's a
couple of final things i want to say
the first is um our
uh team have written a great insights
report on lab automation we wrote this
for all of our customers and people on
our newsletter
to give them a bit more of an overview
of the lab automation space
the technology that's there what
processes coming through
so if this talk has in any way
sparked some interest give that a read
there's some
some really great insight in there and
again we'll send that out in an email
after this so you should get um easy
access
to it but if not you can go onto our
website and it's there
um i think
[Music]
before we move on to questions the thing
that i want to do though is
go back to a slide that i shared earlier
where i talked about this this
imbalance between the perception of
where automation
is versus the reality and that reality
being a place
where we have scientists doing
incredibly mundane repetitive tasks
and then struggling with the
reproducibility of their results whether
that's in pathology whether that's in
research or whether that's in
production environments
and what i hope is that the next time we
speak to you in a year or two years time
we can move away from this slide
and instead talk about this one
and start saying that that space of
those brilliant scientists
doing such mundane robestic tasks is
something that
is history and where we are instead
reflects far more what craig
just demoed to you that is what we
picture and we think
and at that point i hope we can really
start to have
the exciting conversation about where
lab
where automation in labs can take us
and where we can go i'll leave it there
and we'll now move on to some
some questions um i think we've been
sent
a few through so i'm going to check this
off
and i guess i'll be obviously
questioning
thank you to me and then okay
so yeah first question we've got here
are what are common applications that
you deploy
yeah i guess you talked about it earlier
and they tend to fit into
three categories so one will be
our robot sat in front of a single bit
of equipment
quite like a liquid handler that we
showed earlier and it's pending that
machine it's loading in my group like
it's loading in files
your standard lab were there and it's
just replacing
uh that person who would otherwise have
to either stand in front of that and
load in very simple stuff all day um
or and free them up to go and do other
things that their better place to go and
do so that's the first thing we tend to
do
very simply is sit in front of a single
piece of lab equipment and load in the
flatware
and the second thing is starting to
think about automating
uh parts of or indeed a fuel battery and
a good example would be
elisa and so there we'd be working with
a liquid handler and then a microplate
washer
alongside that so loading from the plate
washer into the microplate um
into the liquid angler even and then
thereafter you could even think about
adding
a microplate reader or maybe you need to
incubate it thereafter and we start to
build out from that one piece of
equipment to multiple pieces of
equipment
and we have that fuel assay end to end
and the last one to talk about is those
uh higher throughput situations the
likes of the clover testing stuff that
we talked about
and that we are um that you would expect
for more traditional automation
but we're turning around on much quicker
timelines with much more flexibility
baked in
and so applications that we do tend to
fit into those
three things and if you've got something
in mind and maybe it fits into those
categories maybe it doesn't
drop us away and let us know we're
always happy to review videos and take a
look at things and
it should be generally helpful even if
our robot can't do it we're quite well
connected
yeah i think that's correct
i think i guess the big difference
between the staff that we
take versus a lot of people that produce
a robotic arm
is that we very much um want to support
and own
that solution for our customers to make
sure that you get
success i think what we see is that i've
talked to myself
and you need a partner and um what we
want to do is make sure
that in lots of ways we can be that
partner to help you get success
or if at that point we have a different
partner that we work with do we think
it's better placed
maybe location wise or capability-wise
to support you then we do that but
our big focus is less about the robotic
goal which is a massive
tool in what we can do and more about
getting getting any customers success
from their 45-minute solution
um okay so question two is
do you partner with other lab equipment
manufacturers
uh short answer yes and the longer
answer i guess you saw the
open trends earlier they're one of uh a
quite quick growing list of lab
equipment manufacturers that we are
integrating with
and there's a few more in this room that
are scattered around the background and
various
elements of development so and yeah
we're always really excited to add to
that list as well so if you've got
something in mind
let us know and the robot has been built
on an api
which makes integrating with all these
other bits of labware
quite straightforward we often write the
software integration ourselves to make
it as easy as possible for our customers
and so yeah we work with a range of
stuff we've talked about liquid handlers
plate readers plate washers
uh we're working incubators um
plate hotels just really any kind of
standard lab equipment
you can think of and we're probably
either already integrating with it or
ready to integrate with it
so yeah we very commonly partner with
these sorts of companies
and i'm always looking for more yeah i
think great and that that's exactly when
we speak to flexibility that's exactly
what we mean
by ease of then adding on another bit of
check another video
so that it suddenly doing a new
application a new solution
is exactly what we want to enable you to
do this we appreciate
things change okay and then
i guess to sponsor it and maybe you've
already answered how easy is it
to integrate your equipment with other
standard lab equipment so maybe you talk
to that in the bottom
yeah sure so as i've said there it's
built on an api
which is less common in industrial
automation but much more common
in the lab world and what we like to
think about here is we can turn
uh your software engineers or people
from a software background
into into automation innovators and to
people who can
uh code this stuff and so we're built on
that api which makes the connection
really easy
and then the robot itself you saw how
easy that was to program
out there with that drag and drop
functionality uh making the movements
around it
loading stuff in and out really really
straightforward
um so yeah it's something that we
made from the outset from our robot and
making it really easy to do this stuff
and we found that that's translated
really well into the lab worlds
um as nick said we tend to like to
approach it from a solution first
perspective so so we want to
give you as much help as much support
and getting the solution up and running
but the ease of programming means that
once you've got it in there it's
it's really the flexibility that that
brings the big advantage for
for lab technicians so you can change
that process you can add extra things so
yeah ease of use of something that we
care a lot about and
it's something that we've done to make
it flexible and reactive
to your needs scientifically yeah i
think i'll add to that the other
question we get asked quite a lot is do
you integrate with limb
but um the answer is yes again the same
reasons it's all about the
api basically we're built on modern
technology and therefore
um it makes it fairly simple to to
integrate with
data capture for that sort of thing and
i'm going to show you one final question
out there
we'll call it there so the question is
within that automation which markets do
you see
most growth than most um most likely
demand coming from yeah we're really
excited about a lot of different places
in
um automation so we're seeing lots of
exciting stuff
coming through from the tech industry so
testing inspection compliance
um there's a lot going on in
university research labs and biotech and
maybe the one that i'm most excited
about is pathology
and obviously a very hot topic at the
moment
you all know why and but we're seeing a
real need there
from both public bodies and private
bodies for
automation which we've sort of discussed
today that flexible
and robust automation which can come in
and work really quickly
and work within really importantly right
now
an industry that's changing rapidly and
that is reacting to
um a situation that that's
changing day by day or week by week so
and that's where i'm really excited
about that's where we're
seeing a lot of growth is pathology
particularly within that we're talking
um i guess microbiology so the um
copy testing that we've been doing and
also we're seeing lots of exciting stuff
coming through
genomics so-called gm sequencing uh
lots of interesting both applications
there from a scientific perspective but
also from an automation perspective
yeah so i'm super excited about
pathology
but as always there's lots of published
stuff that's coming in and
i'm sure my colleagues would probably
have a different answer than that but
for me personally
uh big pathology yeah i think that i
think it's that
mixture of like need
i think we pride ourselves on our
ability to react quickly
and develop stuff faster than anyone
else i guess it kind of fits with
what we believe we offer or what we i
hope should
our customers feel we've shown we've um
yeah
and that's where i guess it's the most
exciting because it's
it challenges you and tests you
definitely know the team
okay and i think that's it i think
that's all we've got time for
and thank you very much for watching and
i guess
the final thing to say to wrap up which
we said a few times
is if you're thinking about going on
this journey if
you've had bad experiences before and
want
whatever whatever you should just talk
to us we're always happy to advise
we really want all our customers to get
success
so we're not we're very much
incentivized to make sure that
if if it's not the right thing then
we'll tell you and if it is
we'll either support you or find someone
who can and
so thank you for watching i hope you
feel that you've learned something
and and yeah great to talk to you soon
thank you very much